welcome to this video playing for its
car fruits car from the US I've played
five games against this plan and won
three lost two let's see we have them
the Russell limo yeah yeah to be honest
I made a slight slight mistake already
not not theoretically speaking this is a
normal position I but I had intended to
play B takes c6 actually now I have had
taken with the deep on ok it's um it
shouldn't be the end of the world mmhmm
yeah white enjoys a very very healthy
structure good pawns and good piece
yangtze form however black shouldn't be
in terrible shape so fairly solid I
think what I White's natural plan here
is to to play for a cliff waveform let's
see Queen d2 just not really does not
really fit into this a 4 idea but maybe
I'm wrong about a phone not not an
expert on the structure but I was more
thinking about Knight d2 when they form
this kind of idea yeah well now we get
some some trades I don't think I can I
can do much much else then
then allow the trades
yeah i'm i'm planning would have seven
new gay 70
right into my position let's cheeky
I don't see a way to to trip it though
he might have the idea to play B form
that before can beam can be a problem
okay well I don't want to draw of course
it's a bit bit lame to draw some plain
check yeah I know before this could be a
problem before the eye doesn't play it I
still think it was a good move them
before okay and we splaying it and I
don't understand anything of that i have
c 6 protected maybe you overlooked that
this is just blundering a pawn really
raised fairly solid but it's slow just
upon
okay so how do i get ahead here Queen a
for probably create a for a three
directly forcing matters Queen a 3m
yep Queen trade should should lose out
right and he needs to need to retreat
and now i can't take probably should
take and okay the question is I can take
g-form and damage the pawn structure but
it doesn't look right this doesn't look
Luca voyage let's play let's play b3
this is good getting rid of one of those
doubled pawns so I cannot avoid the to
take yeah well now maybe hmm
Karen this those bishop moves can be M
can be tricky
hmmmmm not easy ok let's try to play it
down in not not such a complicated way
in
hmm
tricky very tricky quite quite a number
of interesting tries but I'd like to
break up his pawn structure quickly and
get this Bishop to c5 this should be in
check should be helpful ok just take it
you
if i just take f6 don't don't really see
a great move on please not directly
yeah I've kept I've kept my extra porn
but is it the win questionable with
perfect play problem yeah I'm very well
centralized h3 h3 is really good even
the thing is some it's nothing it's a
queen trait but it's also this porn hang
weight and I don't have time to consider
this up to its to his fullest I have the
check is long yeah okay check keep it
simple time morning only 18 seconds
check
damn [ __ ] will be five check yeah it
promotes I have e5 protected check check
check check mate wow what yeah one of
those few seconds left finishes yeah I'm
not sure if it's uh yeah here just
blundered upon but then I'm not sure if
I played it really correctly yeah but
the complex my play actually Bishop d6
it's maybe even more convincing check
but this keeps quite a substantial edge
because of this nice centralization lots
of end games are winning due to the
superior King position and dumb check
check I think this winds not 100% sure
that almost check a computer says it's
about your interesting why why is it a
dead wrong
and computer wants to play this with
light as a drone
ah because of Bishop b6 yeah okay this
means i would if i go here i can now you
can always take Alice's this is a nice
trick nice trick yeah well this this is
the problem at the end he get the pawn
then this was wasn't a good a good way
to play check yeah yeah then this is
probably a draw here and I shouldn't go
into the endgame or maybe maybe I
shouldn't should play differently before
I mean you have a number a number of
ways I can also play g5 it's not like
he's got many great moves available it's
probably better you have a cop says that
this is winning surprisingly ok King
edge to this always Bishop d6 and
probably you cannot prevent me from at
the end getting the pawn and interesting
ok thanks for watching